- HONEY, SOMEONE'S HERE.
- OH.
OH, HEY [farts],
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
- THANKS FOR HAVING US,
[farts].
THIS IS MY GIRLFRIEND,
- WE'RE SO HAPPY
YOU COULD JOIN US.
- AND THIS IS MY WIFE,
[farts].
- SO THIS IS THE INFAMOUS
[farts] AND [farts].
[farts] HAS TOLD ME
SO MUCH ABOUT YOU BOTH.
- [laughs]
ALL GOOD THINGS I HOPE.
[laughter]
YOU CAN NEVER TRUST [farts].
- HEY, WAIT A MINUTE.
[laughter]
- AND PLEASE, PLEASE,
DON'T CALL ME [farts].
IT MAKES ME THINK
MY MOTHER'S AROUND SOMEPLACE.
- OH.
- HEY, YOU KNOW, WHERE IS
LITTLE [squeaking fart]?
- OH, SHE'S AT [farts]'S HOUSE
FOR A SLUMBER PARTY.
- AH.
- OH, UM, [farts] AND [farts],
THIS IS THE COUPLE
FROM NEW YORK
THAT WE WANTED YOU GUYS
TO MEET.
UH, THIS IS [farts]
AND HER HUSBAND [honking fart].
- THEY'RE GONNA BE IN NEW YORK
FOR A FEW WEEKS,
SO WE WERE HOPING YOU COULD
GIVE THEM SOME TIPS.
- OOH.
- SURE.
- OH, THAT'D BE GREAT.
SO, HOW DO YOU KNOW
[farts] AND [farts]?
- OH, WELL [farts]
AND I WENT TO
[deep, rumbling fart]
SCHOOL OF DRAMATIC ARTS,
BACK WHEN [honking fart]
WAS WORKING IN MIDTOWN.
- MM.
- OH, WHERE DID YOU WORK?
- I WAS AT [farts], [farts],
[farts], AND [bellowing fart]
- OH, THE LAW FIRM.
- HEY!
- OH, HEY.
- HA!
- HOW ARE YOU?
IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
- GOOD TO SEE YOU.
- COME HERE.
HEY, EVERYBODY,
THIS IS
[high-pitched fart].
I WANT YOU MEET
ONE OF MY DEAREST,
OLDEST FRIENDS, [farts].
THIS IS HIS GIRLFRIEND,
[farts].
- HI.
- HEY.
- HELLO.
- OF COURSE, YOU KNOW [farts].
- OH, HI.
- THIS IS [farts],
AND THIS IS HER HUSBAND,
[honking fart].
- HI.
- WHAT A BEAUTIFUL NAME.
YOU KNOW, I KNEW
A [high-pitched fart]
IN GRAD SCHOOL.
all: OH.
- WELL THANK YOU,
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY PRONOUNCED
[high-pitched fart].
- WOW, I SWEAR THAT SOUNDS LIKE
WHAT YOU WERE SAYING.
- I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT
I WAS SAYING.
- I DON'T KNOW.
- ANYWAYS, IT'S LOVELY
TO MEET YOU ALL.
- YEAH, YEAH, OKAY, YES.
[laughter]
- ROBERT.
I'M SO SORRY.
HEINRICH.
I'LL...
SHOW MYSELF TO THE RESTROOM.
- [sighs]
- WOW, UH--
- JEEZ.
- SO RUDE.
- WELL, FOR [farts]'S SAKE.
- YEAH.